the problems with our existing
generation of wind and solar technology
is that they still remain relatively
high cost in comparison to conventional
technologies now part of that is of
course that we don't necessarily account
for the full cost of the conventional
technologies we don't have a price on
carbon for example so we aren't
reflecting the full cost of society of
using coal natural gas or petroleum but
even that set aside it's still a problem
of cost so there's really no alternative
in the near term but to subsidize these
these newer fuels so that we can
eventually get the cost down with
greater dissemination of them and have
them truly able to compete in the
marketplace on their own as you look
farther out there are some so-called
nano technologies and solar that offer
the promises of very cheap power we have
concentrated solar power stations which
are already in a handful of locations
around the world but the significance of
these plants is that they can be used
for baseload electricity and peaking as
well so they really make solar not a not
an intermittent resource anymore they're
also based on being able to capture the
sun rays when they are when the solar
units are working in store the power for
when the Sun isn't there so these types
of things wind is certainly taking off
around the world actually has made many
more advances than solar has in terms of
its absolute contribution the global
energy supplies and there are tremendous
wind resources in many locations of the
world both onshore and increasingly in
various parts of the world we're looking
for offshore wind farms these are
controversial themselves because you
know you're talking about many very very
large windmills you know four or five
hundred feet high in the air and since
they're often in sites that compete with
recreational and other uses they're not
free in a sense of not being a subject
to political debate
well there are other obstacles that
certain regulatory jurisdictions for
example in the United States will argue
that their responsibilities as
regulators is to deliver reliable the
cheapest power available to the
consumers for which they're responsible
for overseeing the rates and they will
argue that while it may have social
benefits that wind and solar very likely
may raise rates in the near term and so
you get some regulators that simply
aren't as vigorous and championing these
newer resources as they might be if they
didn't see their mandate is different
from a mandate to get as much renewable
into the system as possible